[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في بانوراما يقدمها لكم
اليوم ابراهيم بدر ونناقش فيها
مكافحه تهريب المخدرات وتسويه شامله
للازمه السوريه مع ضروره عوده النازحين
الامنه لديارهم توافق سعودي سوري على
ملفات مفصليه فهل تلتزم السلطات السوريه
بها وهل تستطيع السيطره على شبكات تهريب
المخدرات
توتر بين قطبي السودان العسكريين يهدد
استقرار البلاد وينظر بصراع تشعله الطلقه
الاولى فهل ينجح الجيش السوداني بحل ازمه
مروي سلميا وكيف يمكن دمج قوات الدعم
السريع في الجيش دون قتال
عوده سوريا الى محيطها العربي كان العنوان
الابرز لزياره وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض عوده
يستوجب تحقيقها ايجاد حلول لملفات كثيره
عالقه ليس اقلها ملف تهريب المخدرات الذي
يشكل معضله كبيره للمنطقه عموما ويعد ملفا
دوليا صدرت فيه الكثير من المواقف خصوصا
من الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا اللتين
فرضتا عقوبات على كيانات واشخاص في سوريا
بسببه الزياره التي جاءت بدعوه من الامير
فيصل بن فرحان وزير الخارجيه السعودي افضل
عن بيان مشترك تضمن الاتفاق على اهميه حل
الصعوبات الانسانيه وتوفير البيئه
المناسبه لوصول المساعدات لجميع المناطق
في سوريا وهو الامر الذي كانت دمشق ترفضه
سابقا خاصه ايام الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا تهيئه الظروف
اللازمه لعوده اللاجئين والنازحين
السوريين الى مناطقهم وانهاء معاناتهم
وتمكينهم من العوده بامان الى وطنهم نص
واضح تضمنه البيان الى جانب تحقيق تسويه
سياسيه شامله للازمه السوريه تنهي كافه
تداعياتها وتحقق المصالحه الوطنيه وتساهم
في عوده سوريا الى محيطها العربي لتحقيق
ذلك شدد البيان على ضروره دعم مؤسسات
الدوله السوريه لبسط سيطرتها على اراضيها
وانهاء تواجد الميليشيات المسلحه فيها
والتدخلات الخارجيه في الشان السوري
العلاقات السعوديه السوريه
اهم البنود للبيان المشترك التوصل الى حل
سياسي للازمه السوريه
اهميه حل الصعوبات الانسانيه وتوفير
البيئه المناسبه لوصول المساعدات لجميع
المناطق في سوريا تهيئه الظروف اللازمه
لعوده اللاجئين والنازحين السوريين الى
مناطقهم تعزيز الامن ومكافحه الارهاب
بكافه اشكاله وتنظيماته تعزيز التعاون في
مكافحه تهريب المخدرات والاتجار بها دعم
مؤسسات الدوله السوريه لانهاء تواجد
الميليشيات المسلحه والتدخلات الخارجيه في
الشان الداخلي السوري تحقيق تسويه سياسيه
شامله للازمه السوريه بدو اجراءات استئناف
الخدمات القنصليه والرحلات الجويه بين
البلدين
ولمتابعه هذا الموضوع ومناقشه ضمير ابوظبي
فهد جيران الكاتب الصحفي ومن دمشق عبد
الحميد توفيق الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بكما ضيفي العزيزين واسمحلي ان ابدا مع
الاستاذ فهد جيران من ابوظبي استاذ فهد هل
تعتقدون بان الظروف باتت مواتيه الان
لعوده سوريا الى محيطها العربي وما الذي
يقتضيه ويستوجب ذلك
اهلا بك ولضيفك الكريم فعلا يعني عوده
سوريا الى المجال العربي او الفضاء العربي
وقضايا العربي ضروريه ولم يكن هناك ممانعه
من الدول العربيه ضد ذلك وعلى راسها
السعوديه كانت حريصه على ان تكون سوريا
ضمن المجال العربي وهذا له جدول طويل وملف
كبير عبر ال 15 عاما الماضيا حاولت
السعوديه ان تضم النظام السوري الى الفضاء
العربي والى
القضايا التي تهم السوريين
واليوم هناك
بادره حسن نوايا بين مجموعه من الاطراف في
المنطقه وهذا ايضا
يصب في مصلحه الاقتصاد الذي هو عصب حيويه
الشعوب التي تمر الان بازمات كارثيه
واقتصاديه وبخاصه تلك التي ليست لديها
امكانيات او مقومات او التي تعرض صعوبات
ونزاعات او لزلازل وحروب اهليه مدمره
اتذكر في بدايه الازمه السوريه كنت اتحدث
مع الصديق والاستاذ ادونيس وقلت له في تلك
الايام كيف تجد الامور فقال ان هناك ما
يسمى بالدوله الدوله اساسيه
لضبط المجتمع وهذا ما تؤمن به الدول
المعتدله في المنطقه ثم تفريق بين النظام
وبين الدوله النظام قد يرتكب اخطاء قد
يرتكب امور محدده او معينه وانما لابد من
الرهان على بقاء الدوله واليوم عنوان
الشرق الاوسط كان عنوانا جميلا وهو مقتبس
من البيان المشترك بين السعوديه وسوريا
الذي هو يؤكد على باسط سيطره الدوله
تمت اساس تقوم عليه الرؤى الخليجيه ان
الدوله هي التي ممكن ان تساعد في ضبط
الامن ونحن بالسعوديه لدينا حدود مع
العراق الف كيلو متر مع اليمن الف كيلو
متر دولتين
فاشلتين في فتره طويله من الامد تمكن من
حدودهما الارهابيون
واستطاعوا ان يدخلوا الى مواطن محدده وان
يؤسس تنظيمات
ارهابيه وان يهربوا المخدرات وان يهربوا
الاسلحه وان يؤسسوا مجموعه من ربما يعني
موضوع المخدرات كان البيان السعودي نعم
سنناقشه بمزيد من التفصيل لكن دعنا نجيب
على السؤال بشكل عام ثم ندخل الى هذه
التفاصيل
نعم
انا
انا اقول لك انه انا رايي الشخصي الشخصي
وليس لا امثل اي الا رايي الشخصي ان
الدوله هي البديل عن الارهاب لدينا خيارين
الان في العالم اما الدوله او الارهاب
وهذا ما اكدت عليه التسويات التي اسستها
السعوديه سواء في التقارب مع تركيا او
الاتفاق بكين طهران الرياض او لقاء
المقداد والامير فيصل بن فرحان كل هذا
يؤكد على ان الدوله هي الاساس التي الذي
تراهن عليه المملكه العربيه السعوديه لان
لديها رؤيه تنمويه طموحه يقودها الامير
الفذ محمد بن سلمان ولا يمكن مثل ما قال
الفيلسوف الاقتصادي العظيم ادم سميث ان
الاقتصاد هو الذي يقود السياسات وليس
العكس من دون تنميه
وتاسيس اقتصادي وشراكه اقتصاديه بين الدول
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك
تعاطي سياسي وهذا ما اكدته حتى تصريحات
ترامب البارحه مع فوكس نيوز قال مؤكد على
هذا الموضوع لانه رجل الاعمال
كيف تسير امور الدول ان الاقتصاد اساسي
وحيوي
وصلت الفكره بدانا ننطلق من هذه النقطه
لنفتح الحوار مع الاستاذ عبد الحميد توفيق
من دمشق الحميد سمعت ما قاله استاذ فهد هل
تتفق مع هذا الطرح وبرايك هل ادركت دمشق
الان بانه مصلحتها بكل الجوانب سواء
سياسيه الاقتصاديه
تفرض عليها العوده الى محيطها العربي من
جديد وابرز التحديات التي قد تواجهها
لتحقيق هذه العوده
مساء الخير لحضرتك ولضيفك الكريم
اعتقد بان هذه المساله مدركه مسبقا ولكن
كانت الظروف هي التي تحول بين امكانيه
التواصل بين الجانب العربي او في معظمه مع
دمشق وبين دمشق ايضا ومع الجانب العربي لا
شك ان احتياجات السوريه اليوم لا تتوقف
فقط على البعد الاقتصادي انه عنصر اساسي
لاعاده الاعمار لاعاده عجله الحياه
الاقتصاديه للبلد لاعاده الدوره
الاقتصاديه بعد ان تضررت كثيرا البنى
الاقتصاديه والمؤسسات الاقتصاديه وكذلك
الاداء الاقتصادي وانعكس بشكل مباشر على
مؤسسات الدوله وبناها وعلى الحاله
المعيشيه للناس وعلى القوه الشرائيه لليره
السوريه لكن اعتقد بان البعد السياسي ايضا
له شقان الشق الاول ان الحاضنه العربيه
لسوريه لا يمكن التفريط بها ولا يمكن ايضا
للعرب ان يتركوا سوريا نهبا لمشاريع
خارجيه واقليبيه او غير اقليميه والبعد
الاخر في هذا الامر الجانب الامني الذي
يمكن ان تحظى به سوريا سينعكس في حالته
الايجابيه على مجمل المنطقه العربيه سواء
المحيط الجغرافي المباشر او على العمل
الامني القومي الامني القومي العربي بشكل
عام وكذلك على سوريا حين يكون هناك هذا
التفاهم حين يكون هذا التنسيق حين يكون
هناك هذا التجاوب بين مصالح الدول العربيه
ولنتجاوز مساله العواطف ونتجاوز مساله
النخوه والشهامه هذه هذا منطق مصالح فرض
نفسه على الجميع على سوريا اولا وعلى
العمل العالم العربي ثانيا سوريا حين علقت
على
عضويتها في الجامعه العربيه في عام 2011
منعت من التواصل تحت سقف عربي رسمي ولكن
اعتقد لابد من النظر اذا جانب اخر في
مساله الامن القومي العربي عموما باختصار
التجربه العراقيه التي مرت على العراق منذ
تسعينيات القرن الماضي وحتى قبل بضع سنوات
قليله اعطت البرهان الساطع على ان خلل
الامن العربي في منطقه حيويه من اي جانب
عربي سيؤثر على مجمل المنطقه العربيه في
تلك المرحله في العقود الثلاثه الماضيه
بات العراق ونهبا لمشاريع مختلفه سواء
اقليميه او داخليه ليست وطنيه بالتالي
اعتقد بان اليوم الحراك الذي تتوجه به
يتوجه العرب باتجاه دمشق به هو ايضا حراك
لا يمكن ان يتم الا اذا كان هناك تجاوب من
قبل الجانب السوري وتفاعل وقد بدا واضحا
خلال المواقف التي ظهرت في الاونه الاخيره
من المسؤولين السوريين والجانب السوريين
على انهم يرحبون بمثل هذه التوجهات بهذه
الخطوات وربما كانت المساله الدبلوماسيه
التي حثت خطاها بعد الزلزال باتجاه دمشق
قد حركت كثيرا من الجنود في الساحه
العربيه جاءت الخطوه السعوديه في الحقيقه
لتتوج هذه الخطوات وبالتالي التحديات التي
تسال حضرتك عنها اعتقد بين سوريا والجانب
العربي ربما دعنا ندخل في سوريا حاليا في
ابرز ما جاء في البيان السعودي السوري في
اعقاب زياره وزير الخارجي السوري الى
الرياض ونناقشها بعجاله هناك نقاط رئيسيه
لعل موضوع تهريب المخدرات بشكل معضله
كبيره للمنطقه استاذ توفيق واصبح ملف دولي
يعني هناك يعني عقوبات فرضت على كندا داخل
سوريا بسبب تصنيع وتهريب المخدرات
باعتقادات هل تستطيع السلطات السوريه وقف
تصنيع وتهريب المخدرات
اعتقد بان هذا الملف ايضا هو حين يرد في
البيان الختامي فهذا يعني انه تم طرحه وتم
تداوله وربما ايضا
كان هناك من قبل الطرف السوري ومن قبل
الطرف السعودي وكافه العرب الذين تحدثوا
بهذا الامر الاستعداد للعمل سويا في طي
صفحه هذا الملف هذا الموضوع الذي بدا
شائكا وبدا يتوسع وايضا فعلا هو اتى بكثير
من العقوبات التي لا تنقص سوريا اساسا ولا
تنقص الشعب السوري في اطار مكافحه هذا
الموضوع لابد ايضا من الحديث عن ان مثل
هذا الموضوع الذي يشكل هاجسا وقلقا للدول
العربيه في هذا الاطار لابد ايضا من وضع
حد له وتطويقه اذا كان الامر يتعلق
بامكانيات وقدرات الجانب السوري فاعتقد
بان الدوله السوريه في الاراضي التي تسيطر
عليها لن تجد
من العمل في هذا الاطار وكبح جماع هذه
العمليات لكن السؤال
عن تصنيع وتهريب المخدرات
سيد عبد الحميد نعلم بان سوريا يعني تسيطر
على حدودها خصوصا المتاخم لهذه الدول
العربيه
نعم انا لا اقول لا اقول نعم سوريا تسيطر
اقول بان الدوله السوريه في الاراضي التي
تسيطر عليها لابد ان تقول ان يكون لديها
كثير من الاجراءات والعمليات الرسميه
بالتشارك مع الدول الاخرى لان المساله هي
لا تقف عند جانب معين هناك تجار محترفون
هناك
نتحول بالسؤال السيد فهد باعتقادك انه هذا
الملف الذي يعني يمثل هاجس كما تحدث
الاستاذ عبد الحميد هل يمكن حله هل ستقوم
سوريا بالتعامل معه بحزم لان هذه المشكله
تفاقمت مؤخرا بشكل كبير
بالتاكيد يعني تجاره المخدرات في سوريا او
عبر لبنان او عبر اليمن او عبر الحدود
المختلفه الموجوده لكن في سوريا كانت اضخم
تجاره مخدرات عرفناها في العصر الحديث
وهذا جزء اساسي من
الاجتماع الذي حصل بين الطرفين لابد من
وضع حد لمثل هذا الموضوع المقلق لدول
الخليج والتهريب ممنهج ومنظم ومؤسس
والدوله السوريه تعلم ان هذا الموضوع لابد
من حله بشكل جذري ولكن مثله بعد اتفاق بين
اي بلدين في اوائل الايام لابد ان يكون
هناك اختبار حسن نوايا ان يكون هناك نوع
من جس النبض ان يكون هناك نوع من ان تمشي
خطوه ثم يمشي خطوتين ثم وهو يمشي خطوتين
وانت تمشي خطوه وهكذا فتتصلون الى فيصل
الانسان فتصل الدول الى نقاط محدده يمكن
البناء عليها وهذا ما تسعى اليه السعوديه
مع مختلف الاطراف التي
اختلفت معها في فترات محدده من خلال
السنوات الماضيه الان نحن نعيش مرحله ما
بعد الربيع العربي السعوديه الان تمشط
المنطقه
زرع الطمانينه لوضع الاقتصاد العربي بشكل
جيد وقالها الامير محمد بن سلمان ان هناك
رؤيه ان هناك رؤيه موجوده في السعوديه ومن
يريد ان ينضم اليها ينضم الان الاقتصاد
الايراني في حيره الاقتصاد السوري لبنان
وضعه سيء للغايه في غايه في غايه الانحطاط
وعلى مشارف انهيار الدوله والدول العربيه
على راسها دول الخليج لا تريد لبنان
الانهيار كذلك لا تريد لسوريا ان تنهار
الدوله
لاسباب بسيطه ان اي انهيار للدوله
يحتاج الى عشرين سنه او 30 سنه من الازمات
الاقتصاديه والازمات
والازمات الاجتماعيه والثقافيه وهذا يؤثر
على جميع دول المنطقه فما بالك اذا كانت
دوله قريبه من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مثل مثل سوريا
هناك اولويات تقوم بها السعوديه مثلا
حينما تحدثنا مثلا حينما تحدثنا عن
المخدرات فان هذا الاتفاق يعني ايضا ان له
مصالح داخليه
للسعوديه لا السعوديه لا تريد ان تخدم
انظمه محدده او اسماء معينه وانما تريد
ضبط المنطقه بما ينعكس على المجتمع
السعودي بداخله ايجابيا نتحدث عن المخدرات
نتحدث عن جيد يعني عمليات فكره انا اعطيتك
مزيد من الوقت لفهم هذه النقطه لكن لا
نناقش عدد اخر من نقاط التي وردت في البان
واتحول الى الاستاذ عبد الحميد اسامه
الحميد يعني موضوع نشاط ميليشيات على
الاراضي السوريه ايضا هذا تحدي كبير هل
ستتمكن دمشق من التعامل مع هذا الموضوع
وهل سيشمل كافه الميليشيات الموجوده على
الاراضي السوريه
في الحقيقه هذا ملف معقد ومتشعب لماذا لان
اليوم على الارض السوريه هناك جيوش متعدده
جيوش
وافقت الدوله السوريه على الاتيان بها
روسيا والوجود الايراني وجيوش لم ترغب ولم
توافق الدوله السوريه على الاتيان بها وهي
القوات الامريكيه التي ترعى اذا سمحت
عندما تتحدث عند عندما نتحدث عن البيان هو
يقول ميليشيات باعتقادك ان الوجود
الايراني في سوريا هو وجود على هيئه جيش
ام ميليشيات
له اشكال مختلفه الموجوده الايراني ليس
مخفيا وهو تحت ضوء الشمس بكل
تصنيفاته وبكل شخوصه سواء في ميليشيات
وهناك وهناك خبراء عسكريين وخبراء امنيين
وكذلك اقتصاد وكل شيء كل موجود تحت هذا
الاطار الذي هو العلاقات المشتركه والبيان
تحدث ليس عن ميليشيات فقط البيان تحدث عن
بسط سيطره الدوله السوريه على كامل
الاراضي ومكافحه المنظمات الارهابيه
وبالتالي اعتقد بانه وسع الدائره حتى لا
يدخل في
حيز ضيق ويرى من رؤيه احاديه اليوم الوجود
التركي على سبيل المثال في الشمال السوري
كذلك الوجود تنظيم القاعده جبهه النصره في
جزء كبير من ادلب المساله هنا اعتقد بانها
تحتاج الى تشارك عربي مع سوريا لماذا لان
هذه الشراكه العربيه السوريه في اطار
حلحله هذا الموضوع وانهائه طبعا لن تكون
بين لتن وضحاها حتى نكون واضحين
العربيه مع سوريا يمكنها ان تدفع باتجاهين
الاتجاه الاول التعامل مع القوى الاقليميه
الموجوده في هذه النقطه مختلفه في تركيا
وايران لو سمحت لي فقط لو سمحت لهذه
النقطه فيما يتعلق بالقوه الاقليميه وحتى
الدوليه هذا يحتاج الى تنسيق دولي واقليمي
معها لكن انا اتحدث عن ما اذا كان هناك
رغبه وقدره لدى دمشق على التعامل مع هذا
الوجود الميليشياوي على اراضيها
الرغبه موجوده طبعا لا يوجد دوله تقبل بان
يكون لديها ميليشيات تسيطر على قرارها او
تؤثر عليه ولكن القدره هنا هذه النقطه
الجوهريه القدره اليوم سوريا ليست قادره
لوحدها بكل وضوح ان تقول ان تخرج اي
ميليشيات سواء كانت من المقربه او من غير
المقربه لها ان تخرجها بقرار او ان تخرجها
بعمليات عسكريه هذا الامر اقول يحتاج الى
تشاركيه في العمل السياسي اولا الدبلوماسي
وبالتالي ووضعه على طاوله التفاوض نحن
نسمع راي الاستاذ فهد موجود
الايرانيه التي غيرت وستغير كثير من ملامح
المنطقه
الايرانيه يمكن ان تستثمر وصلت الفكره هل
يمكن تحقيق تسويه شامله للازمه السوريه
بمعزل عن التنسيق مع القوه العالميه
والاقليميه
الضالع والموجود على الارض في سوريا استاذ
فهد
الكثير يعتقد ان اي اتفاق بين دولتين انه
سيتم بين عشيه وضحاها ثمه امور مركبه
وملفات معقده وتسويات تحتاج الى المزيد من
التفاهم نحن نتحدث عن اتصالات حدثت ما بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والمبعوثه
الاممي في سوريا وبين الصين وبين روسيا
يعني الامور كلها تحتاج الى وقت حتى
تتبلور وانما يجب ان يكون هناك حسن نوايا
بين كافه الاطراف سواء من تركيا او من
ايران على ان تبسط الدوله السوريه سيادتها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تؤكد دائما على
مفهوم السياده مفهوم السياده مفهوم محرم
اللعبه فيه يعني ولذلك سوريا تستحق ان
تكون الدوله سيده على اراضيها كافه سواء
عبر
التسويات التي حصلت مع دول الخليج او عبر
التفاهمات التي بدات مواكيرها مع او عبر
الامل المامول يعني ان تخرج الميليشيات
الايرانيه من سوريا عوده اللاجئين
والنازحين الى سوريا وتامين يعني وجود لهم
امن دون اي ملاحقات وسبل عايش باعتقادك
استاذ فهد هذا تحدي سهل ام انه معقد معقد
جدا والان نتحدث مثلا لبنان دوله بنيت على
ان تعيش او تعيش ثلاث ملايين شخص الان عن
بين اراد على اراضيها اكثر من عشره مليون
وهناك ارهاق للمؤسسات
والاقتصاد والى اخره هذا موضوع معقد لدوله
لم تستطع بدي الدوله ما فيها بنوك يعني
دوله ما فيها اساسيات العيش البنوك الصرف
الصحي الكهرباء الماء يعني امور موجوده
حتى في مجاهل مجاهل الدول الاخرى
انما هذا التحدي ينعقد على التسويه التي
ستحدث في حاله تخب رئيس للبنان وكذلك ايضا
المهاجرين في اوروبا ولكن اكبر دوله عنت
من الهجره السوريه هي لبنان التي تعاني
الامرين اليوم ودوله لم تستطع ان تنتخب
رئيس ا ولم تستطع ان تقدم اي جهد يليق
بمثل هذا البلد استاذ عبد الحميد بدقيقه
او اقل من دقيقه موضوع المساعدات وايصالها
الى كل المناطق في سوريا هل هو تحد
بالنسبه لدمشق وهناك تغير في هذا الموقف
لانه خلال الفتره الاخيره بعد الزلزال
رفضت دمشق ايصال المساعدات التي لا تقع
ضمن سيطره هل قررت دمشق تغيير موقفها
لا يا سيدي هي لم ترفضها كان ذلك بوجود
المبعوث الخاص للامم المتحده حين قابلت
الدوله السوريه واعطي القرار وتم دخول
الاشقاء المصريين دخلوا الاشقاء السعوديين
دخلوا الى الاراضي الغير الخاضعه للدوله
السوريه واعتقد بان هذا الملف حين يطرح في
بيان الختامي فاعتقد بانه يراد له التاكيد
على ما يتفضل به ضيفك الكريم ان بسط
السياده سياده الدوله السوريه هو العنوان
الابرز وكل هذه تاتي تفاصيل فيما بعد
بالتالي اعتقد بانه تحدي كبير ولكن يحتاج
الى ان يشترك فيه الجميع سواء تركيا او
لبنان او سوريا وحتى العرب لكي يكونوا
معينين للجانب السوري وللجانب الاقليمي
تركيا وايران في حلحله هذا الموضوع لان
هذا الامر لم يعد قائما على طرف من
الاطراف بالباته عبئا على الجميع ولا بد
من الوصول بكل هذه المساعدات والاغاثات
الى كل المتضررين الاهالينا في الشمال
السوري في الاماكن التي لا تخضعت الدوله
السوريه كان كانت ماساتهم اكبر من الذين
خضعوا يخضعون للدوله السوريه بسبب عدم
وجود هنا تحتيه وبسبب عدم وصول المساعدات
بشكل مبكر في البدايه اعتقد بان هذا الامر
لن يكون تحدي بالنسبه للدوله السوريه
خصوصا بعد التحركات السياسيه والتفاهمات
التي تتوارد يوما بعد يوم مع الجانب
العربي شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا من دمشق
الحميد توفيق الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
والشكر موصول ايضا لضيف من ابو ظبي فهد
شجيران الكاتب الصحفي كنت معنا عبر سكاي
فتوى التقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات